well all olympics make history but this
year could go down in the record books
as the hottest summer
games ever as lucy kraft reports some
experts say
tokyo's extreme conditions are a preview
of what's in store for future summer
games
when it sought to host the olympics
tokyo boasted of its ideal climate for
athletes to perform at their best
instead brutal temperatures and humidity
caused a russian archer to faint
triathletes sickened collapsed at the
finish line and a heat-stricken tennis
player was carried off court in a
wheelchair
in fact tokyo temperatures have spiked
faster than the global average
driven by climate change and tokyo's
heat-trapping urban landscape
it's a history university of tokyo
professor makoto yokohari
has studied climate conditions at every
recent summer olympics
i would say that the toku climate is the
worst in the history for these 30 years
or so
with over 50 000 heat stroke cases here
each year
anti-heat stroke gadgets are selling
fast
at tokyo shops like this one ranging
from handheld
cooling tools to neck chilling devices
wearable electric fans are a bestseller
i may look like the michelin man but
these little fans built into my jacket
ensure that no matter where i go
on the hottest nastiest day of summer
i'm always carrying my own personal wind
tunnel
olympic organizers have deployed miss
towers
shaded benches and parasols
the marathon course was paved with a
heat lowering coating
but in the end the marathon was moved to
another city
where temperatures are only slightly
less sizzling
most of the world has become just too
hot for the summer olympics
the choice professor yokohari said is
stark
move the games to a cooler season or
give up on
outdoor competition so the summer
olympics will become the summer
indoor olympics exactly it's a bit weird
but
but i am afraid that that will be the
only way that you can have it in
mid-summer
for cbs this morning saturday lucy craft
tokyo number of the athletes were asked
about this last night during the games
and they said
well listen i've trained and i've tried
to train in hot and humid environments
to get used to it but it's tough and i
guess you can't put a
misting station alongside the hundred
meter dash right probably not don't want
to slow down and they're training all
year it's
not like they are they're professionals
yeah um i would like that coat do they
sell that in new york city
okay it's a jumpsuit right right